[музика]
шановні вступники попри воєнний стан
вступна кампанія у заклади профтехосвіти
набирає обертів Обирайте заклад для
навчання готуйте документи і подавайте
їх з 1 липня до 31 серпня А якщо не
встигнете до набір на вільні місця
триватиме до першого листопада люди з
професійною освітою стануть шалено
затребуваними Бо нам ще разом
відбудовувати країну та й вже зараз на
ринку праці величезний попит на
кваліфікованих робітників в закладі
профтехосвіти ви зможете безкоштовно
навчатися і отримувати стипендію швидко
панувати професію бо навчальна програма
займає від шести місяців до одного року
а також пройти оплачувану студентську
практику обрати заклад і вступити на
бюджет можна у будь-якому регіоні
незалежно від місця реєстрації ще один
аргумент на користь профтеху гарантоване
працевлаштування після випуску приклади
руку до майбутнього України вступай до
профтеху більше про вступну кампанію
знайдете на Дімон у розділі
професійно-технічна освіта а також на
сторінках міністерства в соціальних
мережах тримаємося ми сильні ми Україна
З повагою до вас
[музика]